thank you for coming in and thank you
for staying for desert now and sure like
Molly or building don't be so please
like it avi and some snack like push up
your like blush of are so that leaves
day all of us to all waiting for his
wonderful opportunity to have two
presenters and i think i'm going to
introduce mark known as Professor noise
first then when after his presentation
I'm going to briefly introduce professor
amiga amiga so i don't know like if I
really need to introduce mark mark on
professor notice because he is already
doing gobblers figured his profound
peels but like just just just to do to
follow the convention so his latest book
is a research guide to death instead of
studies which is extremely informative
and useful resource especially like for
teachers like them on hope for students
as well and also in which was Kuragin we
had orange arrow like the successor
yellow who would just gave a paper in
this second panel and also another
recent publications include his
cinema Bible translated world cinema and
also he keeps sensibly wrote on a
Japanese documentary film history
suggests orissa pressure and also
Jackie's second film from the Meiji era
to rushima and also he published talking
at numerous magazines including cinema
Jarrah or film can't don't worry so I'm
today he was he think that he's going to
do shoreham top which I was very excited
to you before yeah so please thank you
thank you very much for these two
interesting papers I had a really like
so I think you you'll notice that with
the third panel always give a longer
time I mean there's time slot is
conference in symposium especially
because the non fiction film collection
on is one of the strongest I'll collect
materials in mokena collection and we
have this is really perfect person to
introduce materials like subjects like
Professor notice and also professor
professor comic dies now working on the
collection and she come still I really
like everyday all is one area that we
have two most wonderful perfect person
and people do present these papers okay
so first um I the professor bonuses
paper introduced extremely interesting
like politics of translation and so I
was very much in treated intrigued
especially because I worked on acid
Ibaka and she was part of my
dissertation topic topic so I guy I
really learned a lot when Professor
analysis paper was published like 10
years ago he was so I us sort of has a
nostalgic well I had a sort of knows
pelvic movement to you and also kind of
remembered when I spoke to you mr Mackey
know about as I guess collection and it
is like you know the huge in his house
he said okay we're going to take a dog
to walk first and I we talked like when
we were walking his dog and then dog did
whatever like he had to do and then like
we came back and like you can kind of
look at materials and sell like
definitely like purpose or notices talk
really like throw me back all these
random point of memories but also like
the very like claustrophobic space like
Billy Elliot in his house I mean like
it's really like oppressive space that
you always wonder like you know what if
you have our an earthquake will be
really crushed under all these books and
then also like this narrow cases with a
little bit like how do you say like it's
not really like you know I'm straight
anymore like it's a little bit like
sentence because of the whole weight of
the books but anyway so um so the
professor Amos is our talk is in a way
related to you the translink old
practice that um professor Bell
introduced in this morning um in terms
so like we all sell
especially like I was interested also
the transition of this documentary film
by Paul Rosa when it became observe
battlefield and in the battlefield was a
written text and so it was a theory and
I want so the translators mistranslation
or misunderstanding or inability to
understand the foreign language all I
provided interesting like different kind
of like discourses on for people in the
circle the film circle but also can we
say that the stay was also a translator
tremendous translator which provided
this narrative framework that people
either have to avoid or like total work
around fortunately join in so also it is
interesting that especially toward the
the enactment of 1939 film law it seems
like this course of the film medium
specificity and also filmmaking
practices series on filmmaking practices
seems to Olga has gone under certain
reconfiguration with this like provided
dominant narrative def state by there
and in which sort of like I I'm sort of
deep learning from this life the notion
of choice
to Banshee that still when a japanese
film can't miss greater narrator who
explained what was going on the field
moderna drunk especially in a dramatic
film well also like newest film did
provide it narrator apps they also
created narratives in a day turn Vidya
and they showed your interpretation so
it was rather like just seen as a
proficient as it was but then like can
tell CI a-- has this freedom of being
bangs you too I wondered so the
professor notices of paper is focused on
this late 1930s culture film this goes
on culture feel horrible for film on
specific like John Rowe created by
German mufa video then tommy the likes
drove idea probably in terms of
historical a chronology she provided
like wider perspective starting like
from the 20th so here when we we just
hard about this like the circles curious
in like discussed heated discussion
about the or films theory and it was an
intellectual community like specific
male-oriented community although
actually was a female translator so like
on the other hand we again have just
like middle class upper middle class
mail community who really wanted to call
them like baby I'm baby doll so like
said another like
overlap being a class that we witness
Armenia's two papers however it seems
like your interests are like in a
different kind of direction going to
different directions so a professor
Tommy tells presentation in terms of a
timeline follows the time karaoke I owe
me a psycho presents here was she with
Anna focus on dramatic films anything oh
yeah presented a very strong connection
with the existing theatrical tradition
like kabuki and filmmaking but Tommy
does time told me to really emphasized a
very specific like materiality of this
film like gold filled my quota or
Cormega and um and her paper any
questions is very dominant attention
like page to the general culture of film
in the 1930s in specifically likes
japanese film history or discourse the
cultured film is probably a term like
you fly in a film history book I'm
japanese film history book which is the
inner the representative tram arm in the
night ivan world that notion what
activity is that we have need to learn
about nineteen thirties in the film
industry or like him history but when
the other hand tobita s question was how
you know what happens if we look at the
material all those kaga ada gosh film
what we will look at not only non
fiction film we see the introduced like
disney film and made available to calm
calm i should say concave about Albert
middle middle class people and also we
see this non fiction film making
by a mature people so we addition to the
app because of this like mobility easy
handling nature of kolkata area so we
also our attention a as eternity of the
prayer italian film movement to you so
it is a very interesting instrument or
like an interesting very interesting
perspective to look at a very very
materiality of this the kogatana to
relieved the history of 1920s and 30s
japanese film and also so also i thought
it was really interesting to you learn
about Coweta because it's really all
turns our attention to that was sort of
a reception space the space of reception
but it's not just like our conventional
idea of reception which is like in a
dark space we want the audience watch
film like history of like a comic
dichotomize like you know parties that
you know like a showing i'm in the film
the screen and i'm in showing on the
screen and in like then the audience
group of people are watching it instead
we see just like overlapping like space
of reception that practitioner is also
the audience and then just like group of
people form their own class not and also
this is not like university village
university circle dislike more like
circles like emerging from this like
Cashin for like they are like hobby um
so I thought it was really interesting
to think about this space of reception
and then also that this also like in
terms of location when we look at by
Japan's nationwide how far ideas in
kogod
I got traveled I mean it told me to
already show ya the other awesome like
ah feels way out like in colonial
territories and then also chauhan's
presentations are like pointed out yeah
we have those films like the most you
can or like other nations in east asia
from the period so I I wonder like how
far these materials like travel also
like in terms of like to even like in
mainland Japan um when we look at that
like theater like the film industry and
development off louisiana's we probably
like connect these ideas with me your
cities in Japan like summer always
actually one of the really the biggest
cities to have like you know movie
theaters but like in that way I told you
osaka kyoto but then can just you know
have a DA travel to like places like
Doctore for example so the space of this
like reception will be also interesting
so i think um I want to make my I just
come in very rare so like I'm just going
to just pose to a question 14 age so one
for a mark professor notice is so you
discuss this like um interesting miss
translation and off Phillies Gary biosig
attack out and then also pointed out
there are the script written by it is
taking over by second out and he sat in
that you know that
a nose in them in the book he's had so
like because of there's like van
pronunciation translation i really like
changed your understanding of film
theory in Japan or I'll do wrote the
scary and you can and then would you
agree or not so what is the role of
commentary in the end I mean eventually
if I'm in the for critics and audience
and the society in general is it really
possible for on be at renunciation could
change an entire reception of the
village history history as scary a TPM
another question I mean I have another
question and is for professor Tommy duck
so I would like to I would appreciate it
if you could speak about sort of like
space on disk Ojeda traveled and also
the sort of motive power consumption or
like of this yoga yoga in an especially
I'll whole life's you know what happened
to the production of these Golgotha yoga
afterwards during total wool and
especially during the Civil War from
many 41 to 45 you don't like the major
studios have difficulty to secure a tree
stock because of the Quinotaur cage of
the old little materials and also
because of the Navy is control over
Prince stock so was the consumption and
production decrease or increase with
Jada say or I would be very curious what
happens to Clemente hey guys during
the early